- Well, let's talk about your movie.
I loved your movie.
- Thank you!
- You're very witty.
I was like, yeah.
You and Roy, your co-star, as well.
I love...it's so witty.
And it's kind of...
Okay, it's called "Confess, Fletch",
and, would you describe it
as kind of like a whodunit?
- Yes, it's based on the
movie from the eighties,
that some of you,
if I'm looking out and
judging ages correctly, you-
- So, I didn't know.
- May actually remember
this, you- (laughs)
- (laughs)
- I didn't actually know!
- The rest, not at all.
No, it's based on a
film from the eighties,
starring Chevy Chase,
- Love.
- But it's really based
on this series of novels
that were written by a
guy named Jeffrey McDonald
in the seventies and the eighties.
And it's based on a detective,
or, actually, an investigative reporter.
- Yeah.
- And the author of the novels himself
was an investigative reporter
for the Boston Globe,
and he kind of took his experiences
and rolled them into this character.
I.M., Irwin Maurice Fletcher.
Famously made popular by Chevy,
but reimagined for us
for the 21st century.
And we have this whole backlog
of books to go through,
and they're all stories,
and there's a lot of
high jinks in whodunits,
and it's just a fun story.
I mean, there's a reason why people like
to read mystery novels.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because they have a beginning,
a middle, and an end, and--
- And the cast of characters,
and all their personalities.
- It's a fun ride, and you know,
you started to see it with...
Maybe some people like "Only
Murders in the Building",
or "Knives Out", or--
- [Kelly] Yeah.
These things that have been really kind of
sparked in the culture recently.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I think that that's
kind of where we are with this film,
and we're excited that
it's gonna be the beginning
of, hopefully, a franchise,
that I can keep playing this guy,
because I need job security.
- (laughs) I loved it though.
I'm not...I never was into whodunit
until somebody had me, like,
I just asked what somebody was reading
'cause they were, like, really into it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it ended up being Agatha Christie.
- [Jon] Oh, yeah.
- And I was like...well,
I didn't know anything
about Agatha Christie,
and so I...I just missed it, I don't know.
And I'd never been into whodunit,
and it got me into whodunit.
And I loved the show for that,
because the whole time
you're kind of, like,
"Wow, is it the weird neighbor?"
- Well, Kenneth Branagh just made
"Murder on the Orient Express"
and "Death on the Nile".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, so those are a similar thing.
Like, I feel like there's
something in the culture
where we're all excited to have
any kind of certainty or something...
a situation where it gets resolved.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It feels like everything right now
in the world is unresolved,
and it it's nice to watch
a story that gets resolved.
- [Kelly] What?
What are you talking about?
What are you referring to?
- I can't imagine any examples.
- No, but I think what's
interesting about this project is,
"Confess, Fletch" is...
it's got that, but, the
level of comedic timing,
like, the humor is so funny!
And that's not generally what I would find
in Agatha Christie or something like that.
- Right.
- So, I liked that.
I think the humor element is awesome.
- It's definitely very
contemporary in its humor.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we have an amazing
cast in this film.
Not only Roy, who'll be
here later, but we have
Marcia Gay Harden,
Annie Mumolo, who plays
the neighbor next door,
who you might remember from "Bridesmaids"
and "Barb and Star Go to Vista Del Mar".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We have John Slattery,
my castmate from "Mad Men",
- [Kelly] It's so good.
- Ayden Mayeri, we have amazing
people all the way through.
We shot it in Boston and
environs around Massachusetts,
so, it was lovely.
- [Kelly] It's a great film.
- Thanks!
- I love, I hope that it's more of, like,
a series, and you could...there's more.
That's cool.
I love the character.
- Well, I hope to come
and sit back on this couch
and tell you all about the sequels.
- Okay, fine!
Well, we have your co-star, Roy Wood Jr.,
he's joining us next,
was that fun to work with him?
You two are funny.
- Roy is, first of all,
he's a phenomenal comedian,
and his work on "The
Daily Show" is amazing.
He's a wildly intelligent guy.
But part of what Roy brought
to the table was, really,
believability in this kind of...
being a legitimate antagonist
for the Fletch character.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And actually thinking, like,
"Well, he has to be a believable cop.
He can't just be some kind
of joke delivery machine."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And Roy has a gravitas to
him that is nicely offset
by his tremendous sense of humor.
- Yeah. He did a great
job of being serious.
And like, you can actually
believe that he was a cop,
but he was very humorous.
- There's a point in the movie where
he slams me up against
a car, where I was like,
"Oh, you were really,
yeah, okay, that...yep!"
- [Kelly] "This is real!"
- "You, you could be a cop."
- Please welcome Roy Wood Jr., everybody!
(funky music)
(audience cheers and applauds)
- How you doing?
Good to see you, brother.
- Wait, I had to ask.
'Cause y'all, I feel like y'all
had to have known each other forever.
Your comedic timing together
is so brilliant on screen.
So how long, like, when
did y'all first meet?
- In makeup.
(Jon laughs)
- No! You didn't know
each other before this?
- I'd seen him around comedy clubs, like,
he's a fan of comedy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So Jon Hamm shows up at
The Comedy Cellar in New York
all the time, but you don't just go over,
(in a silly voice) "Hey, Jon
Hamm, do you like comedy?"
(laughter)
- Especially like that.
- As a comedian, you know, when
you're dealing with someone
that is on that level comedically,
and it was just, it was fun from the jump.
I'm just thankful.
- That's remarkable though,
because y'all do so well together
feeding off of each other,
and, like, your timing.
That's funny that you'd
never met each other.
I wouldn't have guessed that.
- No, it was really, really cool.
- [Kelly] Well, what
was the audition like?
- It was on Zoom.
It was Zoom.
- Well, that helps you connect.
- I don't know if you knew this,
I turned everybody's camera
off when I did the audition.
Because, like, on Zoom, it's
you and Jon Hamm reading,
but then, there's, like,
other people watching,
and, I don't know y'all!
Block, block, block,
block, block, block, block.
(audience laughs)
Because the, the intimidation of just,
number one, trying to do the
role justice, number one,
and you're rebooting something
that's a very celebrated franchise.
So, you don't want be the
person that messes it up.
You want to get it right.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, so, I can't get it right
with all of these extra eyeballs.
- That's intimidating.
- It's like meeting a girl's
family at the holidays.
It was, like, all these
extra family members,
I'm just here to meet Jon Hamm.
- Yeah.
"Why are you here?"
- Yeah. Who are all these other people?
- Wait, so what do you
remember from his audition?
- It's, you know, like, as Roy said,
anytime you're trying to establish
"Well, will there be chemistry
between these two people?"
over zoom, looking at
a screen with a delay,
it's nearly impossible,
but I knew as soon as we
got through the first scene,
I was like, "Well, Roy's got it."
'Cause, as I said, Roy's got a,
first of all, an established,
unbelievably wonderful
sense of humor,
but, a believable...he's a big guy,
and he is a believable person who is
a member of law enforcement.
- Yeah.
- And a guy that you definitely
don't want to be on the wrong side of.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Even though he is very funny.
So, we needed both of those things,
and Roy was able to deliver,
you know, times a million.
- Yeah, oh, it's so good.
Wait, so in "Confess,
Fletch", you play a cop.
So is it true that you
actually have family members
that are cops?
Did they try and give you advice?
- Yeah. They're they're
they're young cops though.
- Well, what does that mean?
They're still real cops.
- Well, no, but in the movie
I'm a grizzled veteran detective.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- The cops in my family, they're like,
28, 29, you know?
They still got energy,
and they found out I was getting the role,
I didn't tell you this.
They're like, "Oh, well,
let me know if you need
me on set as a consultant,
you know, if you need to learn something."
- [Jon] Let me get that
free trip to Boston.
- Yeah.
"Well, you know you might need to learn
some weapons training, what kind of gun
does your character use?
Or maybe some car chasing,
I could teach you defensive driving."
Hey man.
I'm a cop with a newborn baby
chasing a barefoot white man.
That's all I'm doing in the movie.
- It's not that deep.
- If I get cast in "Bad
Boys 4" I'll let you know.
- Thank you for your advice.
- Yeah. We can do all
the hand-to-hand combat.
- I love that.
So, wait, how do you
guys think that you'd do
solving a real life murder?
Are you good at stuff like that?
Like, guessing things?
- I mean, I have, I've made it through
50, some odd years on this planet.
I think I'm relatively intuitive.
I don't know if I'd want anybody
depending on me to solve anything.
- I'd be good.
- Okay.
(audience laughs)
- I love it, he's, like,
kinda humble, he's like
"Oh, I'd nail it."
- All you have to do to be a detective
is just send stuff to the lab.
(audience laughs)
That's all they do.
They stare at something...
"There it is."
- [Kelly] There it is.
- Get that back to the lab.
- Send that to the lab.
(audience laughs)
- And that's it.
- And you just solved the case.
- And then, you wait for the lab to call,
and the lab will tell you who did it,
and then you go get 'em.
- Oh my God...I think it's a
little different in real life.